aujourd'hui on va voir l'un des trucs
les plus déroutants par rapport à
l'infini les fractions rationnelle sont
à la fois partout et nulle part
commençons par voir pourquoi elles sont
partout considérez de coin sur la droite
des réelles quand on augmente le
dénominateur des fractions on obtient
des fractions de plus en plus nombreuses
sur la droite des réelles en fait en
choisissant un dénominateur plus grand
que l' inverse de la distance entre les
deux points on est sûr qu'une fraction
avec ce dénominateur va tomber entre les
deux points et cette remarque est vrai
même si les deux points que l'on avait
choisi sont très très très très très
près l'un de l'autre
voilà qui montre que les fractions
rationnelle sont vraiment partout
al'inverse tous pourront peut être
encadrés indéfiniment précisément entre
de nombreux rationnelle c'est d'ailleurs
comme ça qu'on définit et nombre réel
les nombres réels sont une ombre qui
peuvent être approximer aussi près que
l'on veut par des fractions rationnelle
on dit parfois que q l'ensemble des
nombreux rationnel dans ce temps m bref
comme vous le voyez les fractions
nationale sont en fait partout et ça je
suis sûr que vous le saviez plus ou
moins ce qui est plus étrange c'est que
ces mêmes fraction rationnelle sont
aussi nulle part commençons par une
façon peu rigoureuse de comprendre cela
imagine tirer un nombre réel au hasard
décimales par décimales un tel nombre
sera une fraction rationnelle cissé
décimales finissent par se répéter une
infinité de fois mais quelle est la
probabilité qu en tirant des décimales
au hasard on finisse par se répéter
je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez
mais tiré deux ou trois fois la même
suite exacte de chiffres pointent
peut-être plus ou moins plausibles me
tirer une infinité deux fois la même
suite de chiffres sans jamais faire
aucune erreur
là ça paraît impossible et on peut
prouver mathématiquement que cela est
impossible
autrement dit la probabilité lorsque
l'on tire au hasard un nombre que ce
nombre soit une fraction rationnel est
égal à zéro
et ça ça devrait vraiment vous
surprendre l'effraction sont partout
mais il est impossible d'en tirer une au
hasard
mais il ya une autre façon peut être
encore plus étrange de comprendre
l'absence totale des fractions rationnel
dans l'ensemble des nombres réels entre
0 et 1
accrochez vous ça va vous retourner le
cerveau concentrons nous sur le segment
01 uniquement supposons qu'il fasse un
mètre de long dans ce segment il y a
deux fractions dont le dénominateur et
un les points 0 et 1
je vais recouvrir le zéro avec un tissu
de largeur un demi centimètre et le 1
avec un tissu deux fois plus petit donc
de largeur un quart de centimètre
ensuite il y a trois fractions de
dénominateur de l'épreuve 0 / 2 1/2 et
de débit encore une fois je les recouvre
avec des tissus toujours deux fois plus
petit qu'il faut donc respectivement 1
8e 1 16e et un 32e de centimètres puis
on a quatre fractions de dénominateurs
trois que je recouvre avec des tissus de
largeur 1 64e 1 128e 1 200 56e et 1 500
12e 2 cm et ainsi de suite
la première remarque c'est que si je
continue ce procédé à l'infini j'aurais
recouvert toutes les fractions
rationnelle en effet la fraction paix
est sûr qu sera recouverte à la cuillère
étape de ce procédé
plus étrange encore toute fraction
rationnelle sera recouverte par un
nombre infini de tissu je vais pas
expliquer pourquoi dans cette vidéo si
on ne comprenait pas c'est pas grave
je vous invite quand même à y réfléchir
mais il y a plus étrange encore voici la
question de la mort qui tue à l'infini
pensez vous que recouvert tout le
segment zéro
qu'en pensez vous n'hésitez vraiment pas
à mettre pause man et a cherché à
répondre à cette question par vous même
pour recouvrir 0 on a utilisé un demi
centimètre
puis pour recouvrir un on a utilisé un
quart de centimètre
puis pour 0 / dehors d'utiliser un
huitième de centimètres puis un 16e et
ainsi de suite
du coup la quantité totale de tissu que
l'on aura utilisé et en cm 1 demi plus
un car plus un huitième et ainsi de
suite
or cet infini c'est une somme bien connu
on peut par exemple a calculé en baisse
2 ce qui nous donne 0,1 +0 01 plus 0,001
et ainsi de suite à l'infini qui est
idéal à 0,1 au qui par le même argument
que celui de l'épisode 2 est en fait
égal à 1
du coup la longueur totale de tissu qui
nous aura fallu pour recouvrir toutes
les fractions et d'un centimètre or ce
que le tissu a recouvert est forcément
moins que la longueur de tissus utilisés
du coup la partie du segment qui a été
recouverte par du tissu est forcément
inférieur en longueur à 1 cm comme le
segment 01 faisait 1 m ça veut dire
qu'on n'a pas recouvert plus d'un pour
cent du segment zéro un incroyable je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte de
la mesure de ce qu'on vient de mesurer
on a montré que l'on pouvait recouvrir
toutes les fractions de l'ensemble 0 1
avec des bouts de tissu qui recouvre
moins d'un centième du segment zéro
quand je dis que les fractions sont
vraiment nulle part elles représentent
moins d'un centième du segment 0 1
pire encore si on a obtenu ce nombre de
20 centièmes c'est parce que l'on a
commencé par recouvrir le zéro avec un
tissu d'un demi centimètre
mais si on était parti d'un demi
millimètre ou d'un demi micromètres ou
même d'un demi nanomètres n'aurait
besoin que d'un anneau mètres de tissu
pour recouvrir toutes les fractions et
l'on aurait alors conclu que les
fractions représente moins d'un
milliardième du segment zéro en poussant
ce raisonnement une deuxième fois à
l'infini on est forcé de conclure que
les fractions rationnelle représente une
fraction du segment zéro un plus petit
que n'importe quelle quantité
strictement positive
la conclusion est inéluctable
l'effraction rationnelle ont une
présence nul dans le segment 0 1 ont dit
qu'ils forment un ensemble de mesures
nul ou encore un ensemble de mesures
négligeable voilà qui pose des problèmes
métaphysiques
incroyable quand j'étais au lycée un
cancre de la classe s'amusait à troller
ses camarades avec le paradoxe suivant 6
1 points à une mesure strictement
positive alors un segment qui est
composé d'une infinité de points devrait
avoir une mesure infinie mais 6,1 points
à une longueur nul alors peu importe la
quantité de points que je mène en
enseignements la longueur du segment qui
va être la somme des longueurs des
différents points qui composent ce
segment devra lui aussi être de mesure
nulle
je me souviens que l'épousé l'aide de la
classe s'était moqué de cette co mark
parce qu'elle a été annoncée par cet
élève cancres mais cette remarque était
incroyablement profonde et je passais la
nuit à y réfléchir
j'avais fini par conclure que la
longueur d'un point devait forcément
être ni
ni strictement positive elle devait être
infiniment petit
elle devait être un infinitésimale
galilée leibniz et euler aurait sans
doute été d'accord avec moi mais
l'histoire nous a donné tort en 1904 le
mathématicien henri lebègue développa
enfin une théorie mathématique de la
mesure et oui il aura fallu attendre
1904 pour que les mathématiciens sache
enfin rigoureusement mesurer leur objet
mathématique
or dans la théorie de lebègue la
longueur des points est nul
tout comme l'ensemble des fractions
rationnelle plus généralement dans la
théorie de lebègue tout seul dénombrable
2 0 est toujours égale à zéro ça paraît
évident dit comme ça mais ça n'a rien
d'évident c'est incroyablement subtil le
mot important dans ce que je viens de
dire le mot dénombrable david de
sciences étonnante et religions dont
déjà longuement parlé je vais pas tout
réexpliquer mu en bref l'ensemble des
points entre 0 et 1 n'est pas
dénombrable il les indénombrables ce qui
veut dire qu'en gros il est trop gros
cet espace pour qu'on puisse lister ces
éléments 1 à 1 2 ans jusqu'à l'infini on
reviendra d'ailleurs longuement sur la
preuve de ce théorème dans un épisode
cette formule à linverse l'ensemble des
nombres rationnel entre 0 et 1 et lui
dénombrable puisqu'on la liste et
précédemment pour notamment choisir les
longueurs des bouts de tissus pour
recouvrir chacun des nombreux
rationnelle en fait l'ensemble de tous
les rationnels est aussi un ensemble
dénombrable et je vais pas refaire la
preuve puisque l j j essaie ensuite
nantes
très bien fait dans ces deux vidéos or
toutes ensemble dénombrable et de
mesures nul puisqu'il est la somme des
longueurs des éléments qui composent cet
ensemble donc en théorie de lebègue on
peut dire qu'une somme dénombrable 2 0
est égal à zéro
cependant le segment 01 lui est composé
d'une quantité indénombrables de points
et c'est parce qu'il est composé d'une
quantité indénombrables de poing qui
peut ne pas être deux longueurs nul
autrement dit on pourrait dire si les
puristes ne vont pas eu d'accord qu'une
somme indénombrables 2 0 peut prendre
des valeurs non tenues et c'est ça qui
résout le troll de l'étudiant la lymphe
en a parlé de huit monstres des
mathématiques encore que vous avez été
super génial avec tout plein de
questions super intéressante
encore une fois je vais pas pouvoir
répondre à toutes vos questions et je
m'en excuse
angie clan official leader nous
demandent pourquoi est-ce que la surface
de la trompette de gabriel est infinie
ap répondre à cette question ce qu'on va
faire ce qu'on va décomposer la
trompette de gabriel en bout de longues
heures et sur chaque goût de longueur 1
on sait que la surface de la tourne pas
doit être plus grande que la surface
d'un cylindre qui va être inscrit dans
la trompette donc par exemple entre 1 et
2 on voit que la surface de ce cylindre
qui est égal à un taux fois la hauteur
fois le rayon du cylindre la hauteur ici
c'est qu'à la longueur et le rayon de ce
silence est égal à 1 sur xbla x va être
l'abscisse du point le plus à droite
qu'ici c'est égal à 2 donc pour le
premier bout la surface va être
supérieur divisé par deux ensuite pour
le deuxième bout on peut voir que la
surface de votre supérieur à taux divisé
par trois et ainsi de suite
du coup ça samedi que la surface totale
de la trompette de gabriel va être
supérieur à la somme des taux divisé par
m
ces gars là deux fois la somme d 1 sur
nsmb sur un swing c'est la somme
harmonique dont on a déjà parlé dans
l'épisode 3 et on sait que ça ça me tend
vers l'infini
du coup la surface de gabriele plus
grande qu'une série qui tend vers
l'infini
elle est donc l'infini elle aussi mais
inverse de volume la trompette de
gabriel lui est parfaitement fini pour
voir ça on va prendre cette fois les
cylindres circonscrite qui sont ô toi
dont le volume est forcément plus grand
que le volume à l'intérieur de la
trompette donc cette fois le volume d'un
cylindre ça va être un demi de thau fois
la hauteur fois le rayon au cari du bus
pour le premier bout ça va être un demi
de thau foire encore à la hauteur des
ailes à 1 et 7 x 1 sur x au carré os x
et l'ailé gauche
donc ça nous fait un demi de thau / 1 au
cari ensuite pour le second but on voit
que le volume à l'intérieur de la
trompette de gabriel être supérieur à un
demi de taux divisé par deux car et
ensuite un demi-tonneau visé par trois
quarts et ainsi de suite du coup le
volume total de la trompette de gabriel
peut être inférieure à 1 2 me de thau
fois la somme d 1 sur rennes au carré
cette fois la somme des rassurer nos
gars et ça ça converge c'est quelque
chose qui est égal même un tocard et /
et du coup on voit que le volume à
l'intérieur de la trompette de cap et
elle va forcément être inférieur à tous
occupent / 48 et je vous propose en
exercice par dont il pouvait mettre dans
les commentaires comment calculer de
façon exacte le volume à l'intérieur de
la tombe et de gabriel illusionniste fr
nous demande s'il ya un lien entre la
diagonale biscornu est quelque chose que
j'avais présenté dans le documentaire
sur la magie des maths de prix pain et
bien oui en effet c'est à peu près la
même chose et je vous invite vraiment
aller voir sept documentaires si vous
voulez beaucoup mieux comprendre
pourquoi cette diagonale biscornu à une
longueur qui peut toujours être égal à 2
tout en convergeant
vers une diagonale dans la longueur et
dégâts la racine carrée de 2 et enfin
vous avez été nombreux à me demander
d'expliquer le concept de dimension et
en fait je pensais que michaël lehoux
gilles avait expliqué qu'en fait ils ont
pas expliqué pour comprendre le concept
de dimension va reprendre le tapis de
cherpines ce qui fait que le prince bien
cette fois sur pink slip
donc là on a un tapis des cherpines ce
qui à une certaine échelle est la
question que je vous pouvez c'est
comment mais il faut de billes de
petites billes de disques pour recouvrir
tout le tapis de cirque en ski et là on
se rend compte qu'on peut recouvrir tous
le tapis avec 8 bis ensuite ce qu'on va
faire c'est qu'on va agrandir le tapis
de cire pinsky sans agrandir les bio on
va utiliser pour le recouvrir donc on va
par exemple on propose 2 x 3 toutes les
distances donc on effectue une
homothétie de rapports 3 du triangle de
chygrynskiy et une beaucoup plus grande
et à question intéressante c'est à voir
au mieux il faut de bip ou maintenant le
remplir et là on se rend compte qu'il
faut soixante quatre billes pour remplir
le tapis de cyrine ce qui du coup si
l'on récapitule lorsque j'agrandis le
tapis des cherpines ski d'un facteur
trois le nombre de billes qui me faut
maintenant pour le recouvrir et x 8
c'est de 8 à 64 plus généralement la
question qu'on va se poser c'est si on
fait une énorme homothétie multiplie sa
part à facteur x très très très très
grand par combien je devrais multiplier
au nombre de billes pour pouvoir encore
recouvrir tout le tapis de sirkin ski
super a grandi et bien si le tapis de
sirkin ce qui était de dimension 1 le
nombre de vies qu'il faudrait serait
juste x le même facteur x
si le tapis de cire peines qu'ils
étaient deux dimensions de biens le
nombre de vies qui me faudrait cela x x
carré et du couple via mange pas si vous
vous sentez venir
mais la dimension du tapis de cire
pinsky peut être telle que le nombre de
billes qu'il faut pour l'ouvrir va être
multiplié par x puissance des en fait
plus généralement la dimension d'un
espace
rectal ça va être défini comme la
puissance d ici qu'il faut associer à x
tel que lorsque j'ai fait qu'une nnomo
taissy d'un facteur x de la figure
fractale le nombre de boules pour
recouvrir la structure fractale très
agrandie sera alors multiplié par x
puissance d alors pour être bien
rigoureux il faut introduire coup c'est
de limiter pour limite comme il le faut
mais intuitivement là dans notre exemple
on peut appliquer ce qu'on vient dire on
a vu que lorsqu'on multiplié les
distances par trois il fallait
multiplier le nombre de bipar 8 du coût
8 doit-être trois puissances d du coup
on à l'équation 8 est égal à trois
puissances d où l'inconnu on cherche à
connaître c'est la dimension des du
tapis de sirkin ce qui est là pour
résoudre cette équation
j'applique eux les logs des deux côtés
et puis je divise par l'oc ii 3d vos
côtés et j'obtiens des dégâts à l'oc ii
8 / logs 3par pour bien sentir ce
concept de dimensions je vous propose
d'appliquer ce qu'on vient de dire à
l'eponge de menger et bien les projets
mais niort là on voit que je les ai
recouvert avec une bille et si je
multiplie toutes les distances par trois
il va me falloir maintenant 20 bis où il
y aura vingt morceaux qu'il faudra
recouvrir avec le même volume que
j'avais pour recouvrir les proches de
menger initial et ça ça veut dire que 20
doit être égale à 3 le 3 c'est le
facteur d'agrandissement puissance la
dimension du l'eponge de menger du coup
on a cette fois 20 est égal à 3
puissance d un coin soit on prend les
log des deux côtés on divise on trouve
des est égal à loeb de 20 / look de 3
notre façon peut-être de court circuiter
un peu ce raisonnement sur l'ebit qui
énorme le vrai raisonnement qu'il
faudrait faire mais bon parfois qu'on a
les structures aussi simple que celle là
eh bien on peut le ce court circuiter et
bien c'est de voir que les poteaux
munger est composée de vingt copies
identiques de lépanges de manière elle
même qui sont toutes avec des longueurs
trois fois plus petit qui vont sublime
homothétie de rapport un tiers une
course qu'un objet contient 20 copies de
lui-même qui sont trois fois plus petit
sa dimension fractale
être locke de 20 / look de 3 je vous
propose d'appliquer sa à la courbe de
liberté on voit que la courbe de
gilberte contient quatre copies
d'elle-même qui sont chacune deux fois
plus petit
du coup la dimension fractales de la
courbe de l'ibère tu dois être loggé de
4 / l'oc ii 2 et là je suis pas si vous
connaissez bien les log mais loeb de 4 c
log de deux carrés et donc de loeb et de
karine on peut sortir le 2 c'est deux
fois l'ocde 2 les logs de se simplifient
et donc on retrouve que la dimension
fractales courbe de pertes est bien
égale à deux correspondent bien en fait
qu'elle recouvre un plan elle j'espère
que vous avez aimé cet épisode qui est
le dernier épisode où on insiste
beaucoup sur les bizarreries de l'infini
maintenant qu'on a plein de monstres et
plein de bizarreries mathématiques la
partie du prochain épisode on va essayer
de structurer tout ça de s'assurer que
tout ce qu'on a vu jusque là a un sens
autrement dit on va faire deux
l'axiomatique va essayer de se poser la
question de caisse que la vérité en
mathématiques et ce avec tout ça et en
particules la prochaine fois on va
parler de l'arithmétique de paix à
nantes
vous avez aimé cet épisode penser à la
ligue et à le commenter le partager
pensez à vous abonner pour les
caricatures épisode
merci équipe leur polar dont j'espère
qu'ils me verrai la prochaine fois on
tient ventes là un membre qui appartient
qu est que ce nombre là se trouve entre
vérin et perd 2